So this, is my exposure triangle, shutter speed, aperture, ISO.
By changing the aperture,
we can actually can impact the depth of field, increasing ISO,
we get more grain, and decreasing the shutter speed, we can get motion blur.
So, it's a combination of these three things,
that allows you to explore how we can actually, best take the pictures we want.
So, aperture opening, is one of the parameters we want to to control,
shutter speed, that is how long do I want to keep the shutter open to
get the amount of light in, to my sensor is something I want to do, and
once it hits the sensor, I want to actually know more about the sensitivity of
the film, or, the digital sensor that we're using.
And again, photographers basically optimize these based on
their experience to get a desired exposure.
On the website for this class,
I'm going to put a small applet that actually people at Stanford built,
that will let you explore, the variability of the these three to be able to
get the best exposure in a synthetic kind of a play around mode.